- [Sal] What we're going
to do is think about
the graphs of marginal utility
and total utility curves.
And so right over here,
I have a table showing me
the marginal utility I get
from getting tennis balls.
And so it says look if
I have no tennis balls
and I'm not able to play tennis,
so I'm pretty happy when
I get that first ball.
It gives me a marginal utility of 100.
Now you might say 100 what Sal?
And I would say to you
well that's the thing
about marginal utility.
We're using fairly abstract units here.
We're not speaking in terms of dollar
or opportunity cost.
We're just have this abstract unit,
we could call it utility units if we want,
but what really matters is the relation
between these values.
So for example, that second ball,
it's nice, now I can lose that first ball
or I don't have to chase
that first ball around
as frequently, but it's not as,
I don't get as much incremental utility
as I got from that first ball.
That first ball allowed me to play tennis.
Now the second ball,
I was already playing tennis,
now my tennis is just going to be
a little bit more pleasant.
So the marginal utility
one way to think about it,
this is 80 and this is 100,
the marginal utility of
that second ball is 80%
of what that first ball is.
Now I promised that I would graph these,
so let's get a graph out here
So there we go.
And let's start plotting these
and see what it looks like.
Well that first ball
gave me a utility of 100.
The second ball gives me a utility of 80.
Third ball, you see the trend.
This is a downward sloping,
if this was a line, these
are discrete values here,
but if I cared about 1/2 of a tennis ball
or 3/4 of a tennis ball,
then I could connect
the dots here as well.
But you can see that it
is downward sloping line
if you were to connect the dots.
So three balls, utility of 60.
If I have four balls,
it's a utility of 40.
Five balls, utility of 20.
And once again, when
I get that fifth ball,
yeah it's nice, but now my
pockets are getting pretty full
and I was all, it's hard to play tennis
with those full pockets.
By the time I get that sixth ball,
I get no marginal utility from that.
I don't have a place to store it,
it's I don't really,
I'm not really into it.
And then that seventh ball,
I actually view it as a negative.
It's one extra ball to worry about.
No place to store it, it's
taking up space in my life.
And so if you were to connect the dots,
we're talking about a discrete case,
but oftentimes you could
think about something
that's a little bit more continuous
where the quantity is more
granular if you said pounds
of chocolate or something like that,
then you could imagine
in general for a marginal utility curve,
to be able to connect these dots.
And you see in this case,
it is downward sloping.
So this is the marginal utility,
the marginal utility curve.
Notice that it is slopes down,
slopes down.
And this you're generally
going to see this
for any marginal utility curve
because the incremental
benefit of that next amount,
that next unit, is seldom as good
as the benefit of getting it before.
You get tired of the thing,
you start running out of space,
you've already consumed
more than you need of it.
And this is consistent with what we know
from the law of demand.
And the law of demand,
every incremental amount of quantity,
people are like well I already have some,
and this might not be,
the law of demand is not talking about
just an individual,
it's talking about a market,
but the market as a whole
is made up of individuals,
and if each individual is saying,
hey you know that first
unit really matters to me,
but the next unit, it's
nice, but not as good,
so I'd pay less for it.
And then the unit after that,
it's nice, so I might pay less for it.
And so if you aggregate
all those individuals,
that's where that law
of demand comes from.
These are consistent ideas,
and that's why the demand curve,
you are also, it is sloping down.
Price is usually on this
axis instead of utility,
and you could imagine price
as being a proxy for utility.
And quantity of course is on
this axis right over here.
So this is quantity of balls.
So that's our marginal utility curve.
What about total utility?
So let me
have a table here that
shows total utility.
And total utility from marginal utility
is pretty straightforward.
All you do is say okay,
well that first ball,
when I have one ball, my
total utility is the same
as my marginal utility.
And so you're going to have
that same starting place
at when your consumption
is just beginning.
But then your total
utility from two balls,
well I had 100 utility
units from the first ball,
and then I get 80 more
from that second ball,
so it's gonna be 180.
So for two balls, my total utility is 180.
All I'm doing is I just
added that to that.
Now for three balls I
add that to that to that.
I take 180 and I add the 60 extra
utility units I get for that third ball,
and now I'm at 240.
So that third ball
gives me, gets me to 240
right over there.
Now the fourth ball, once again,
I'm just gonna take 240
and add the incremental
utility of that fourth
ball, the marginal utility
of that fourth ball.
That gets me to 280.
So that gets me to 280,
which is right over,
let's see, 20, 30, 20, 40, 60, 80.
So this is right over there.
Now that fifth ball,
I'm just gonna take the 280
and then the marginal utility
of the fifth ball, add 20, gets me to 300.
Fifth ball gets me to 300 which would be
right around there.
Now the sixth ball gave me no incremental,
no marginal utility,
so my total utility,
when I have six balls,
stays the same.
I'm indifferent as to whether
I have five or six balls.
So the sixth ball, it is
now flat right over here.
And now the seventh ball,
I'm tired of these tennis balls.
I'm being overwhelmed by them.
I'm finding it stressful.
And so it actually has a
negative marginal utility,
and so my total utility,
if someone forced me to have seven balls,
my total utility would now go down by 20.
And so my total utility now would be 280,
right over here.
And you could see the
marginal utilities here,
if you just say look this is plus 80,
this is plus 60,
this is plus 40,
this is plus 20,
this is plus zero,
and then this is minus 20.
And so you see the numbers right over,
right over there.
Now this tennis ball example,
this would be a discrete case.
You wouldn't have 1/2 a tennis ball or
pi tennis balls or something like that,
but if we wanna speak in general terms,
you could think about connecting the dots,
if you had a more continuous example.
And your total utility curve might look
something like this.
Now what's interesting is
right when you're beginning
consumption you're
starting at the same place.
Well that makes sense.
Your first unit, you get marginal utility,
that's gonna be your total utility.
And this is upward sloping as long as
you're getting some
positive marginal utility
from each increment.
So as long as my marginal
utilities were positive,
well this graph
is going to be increasing.
But notice, because the marginal utilities
are getting are decreasing
right over here,
the rate of increase for total utility
is decreasing, the slope
here is decreasing.
You can view the marginal utility
as the slope of the total utility curve.
And then notice the total utility curve
has a maximum value,
it's starting to hit a maximum
value right over there,
when the marginal utility
curve is hitting zero.
Because beyond that point,
where at least in this
example we had negative
marginal utility.
And so when you add that seventh unit,
well that's gonna make your
total utility curve go down,
and so you're gonna have a negative slope
in this particular example.